hi
welcome to pi data global 2020 let's
just jump
right into it before i start all the
code and slides you're going to see
are available on github so you're
welcome to peruse them anytime at your
own leisure you can
change some of the values and run your
own optimizations that you're going to
see in a second
so it's all here for you to have fun
with
what we're going to get into though is
the slides themselves and we're going to
talk about supercharging decision making
with base there
so who am i my name is ravine kumar i'm
either a data scientist or supply chain
engineer or bayesian statistician
depending on who's asking i'm a core
contributor to prime c and rvs both of
these are num focus sponsored so i want
to thank them focus for their
stewardship
of scientific scientific open source
software and of course
for helping put on all the pi datas
including pi data global
[Music]
what i used to do was build supply chain
systems for things like these drill
ships i would help figure out when the
material needed to be
at a certain place at a certain time and
what people needed to be there
to build things like this giant uh drill
ship
i did a very similar thing at spacex and
helped plan out when every rocket launch
for spacex would occur um for a number
of years
and then i did a similar thing in sweet
green but this time happening figure out
how many people we needed in different
locations and what ingredients to get
everyone
the custom salad that they wanted to
have
what i do now is i'm a principal data
scientist and co-founder at pimc labs
pimclabs is a consultancy where we help
organizations sort of supercharge
um their decision making or their models
or whatever
whatever maybe with uh bayesian
statistics
and why bayesian statistics well it
turns out it's
it's a pretty useful and powerful
algorithm um it can do a lot of things
it can characterize outcomes so if the
outcomes we care about are
the weight of all men in california well
basically
bayesian statistics can help you
understand that based
statistics can do latent factor analysis
so it helps you understand
whether age or smoking or diet how they
affect the outcome of
men's weight in california or texas or
china or wherever
um we're not going to talk about either
those two things even though they're
super
they're powerful on their own what we're
going to talk about is how you can use
bayes theorems to make
decisions and so every organization
needs to make decisions whether i was at
spacex or nov
we had to make choices about what to buy
when to buy which suppliers to keep and
we wanted to make um the right ones
typically you know human experience is
where most people use to make their
decisions
when you are with your friends and you
want to get lunch you use human
experience to figure out
where the best places to get lunch but
you can also use data
to figure out what choices you have and
how to make this decision
each choice is tied to an expected
outcome so we take a choice
and given our experience or what data we
have we tend to we tend to have an
estimate of what will
what will happen but what actually
happens is related to but
not exactly what you expect right if
everything you expected to happen
actually happened life would be
a lot better but unfortunately that's
not always the case
what we want to do though and this is
the real chant this is the real trick
is we want to make the choice that leads
to the best
actual outcome we you know the expected
outcome is great but we really want the
best thing to happen
and this is where human experience and
data can both be combined to get us
if we just take human experience the the
years of experience moniker you hear
largely helps bring these two things
closer together as you get
more experience with driving your car
more experience programming and more
experience
snowboarding or particularly activity
you get better at expecting
what's gonna happen and what your
expectation is ends up being
what actually happens when you're very
new you expect to let's say not fall
on your butt when you're snowboarding um
but that's what actually happens because
you don't quite know what you're doing
yet
it's sort of the same thing with machine
learning algorithms when you don't have
a lot of data
it's hard for a machine learning
algorithm or statistics
function to figure out exactly what's
going to happen but as you get more and
more data hopefully
the algorithm can uh can come together
and ideally
you can use both of these things to
narrow down
to the best actual outcome every time
and that's what we want to do with
bayesian statistics bayesian statistics
is a mathematical formula
primarily but i think more importantly
it's a methodology
that helps you characterize that
uncertainty
bayesian statistics is powerful in a
particular way
because it tends to be able to use small
amounts of data
it can leverage small amounts of data
and provide uncertainty to help you make
better decisions
where a lot of other algorithms are
unable to do so
so rather than talk about it at a
philosophical level let's dive into a
specific example
anisha is a newspaper vendor now she
let's say lives in los angeles where i
live
and what she wants to do is buy
newspapers in the morning from the los
angeles times
and she wants to sell them later at
night sorry later in the day
to folks in the los angeles community
she can buy the newspapers wholesale for
five dollars
and she can sell them for seven dollars
the newspapers only last one day
if she buys the newspapers on monday she
can't really sell them on tuesday
because they become they become
worthless nobody wants a dale newspaper
each morning she has to make a choice of
how many she wants to buy and
if she buys too little she loses a bunch
of sales if she buys too many
she wastes the opportunity on uh unsold
papers
so we want to make sure she buys the
right amount of newspapers to maximize
her profit
how can initiation get the best outcome
well this problem
is this is a well-studied operations
research problem called the news vendor
problem
it's also called the single period model
because um the inventory only lasts
a single period and this particular case
a period is is one day
so let's first talk about how to
calculate the profit
if we know the price denisha buys the
news here before and we knows the price
that she sells the newspaper for
and we know the demand and we know the
decision which is how many newspapers
she decided to buy
we can use those to calculate anisha's
profit i want to note that in the
simplest version of this problem
we don't account for the sales she
didn't make we only account for the
transactions that did occur
so putting sort of numbers to paper or
in a second numbers the notebook
jupyter notebook um we have our
newspaper cost for initial here we have
the customer price here
we have the choice anisha made in the
morning which was the buy 42 newspapers
and we're going to assume that demand is
fixed at 40 newspapers we know exactly
40 people want to buy newspapers
what we get here is we have the demand
times the customer price is the revenue
this is how much money anisha has coming
into our business
and then newspaper cost times the amount
of inventory she holds
this is her inventory cost and this is
how much money is leaving her business
how much money she paid for the
newspapers
and in this case she makes 70 worth of
profit
[Music]
let's say anisha then decides to buy 38
newspapers the next day and we're going
to say demand is still fixed at
40 newspapers in this case uh
anisha's um we run the same calculation
but in this case a niche sells that our
inventory so we get 38 times the price
of
of seven this is her revenue again and
then we subtract out
um her inventory costs and in this case
she actually made more money
which is interesting might be surprising
but she made more money because she
didn't lose
any money on its own inventory because
we're going to do that calculation over
and over again
we're going to turn this into a function
and this is everything that we saw
before just in a python function
we have 42 which is anisha's uh
choice of inventory how many she decided
to buy 40 is our demand
we have the same thing over here 38 is
the niece's choice of inventory
and 40 is the demand and here is your
profit
in either scenario because this is pi
data somebody would
yell at me because there's an obvious
one-liner here and so we've took
we've taken that last function and we've
turned it into a handy one-line function
right here the numbers are exactly the
same
[Music]
we can yell use this function to test
out what anisha's profit would be
at every possible inventory choice from
0 to 100.
and so here's what the curve looks like
if anisha buys zero newspapers she's
gonna make zero dollars
not surprising as she buys more and more
newspapers
she makes two dollars per each sale
because she
she buys them for five dollars and she
sells them for seven dollars
so she keeps making a nice profit all
the way up until she gets to 40
and then there's a drop off because for
every additional newspaper and he should
buy is over 40
she loses five dollars because she has
inventory that she
bought but she couldn't sell and if we
get to 80 or 90 newspapers she starts
losing a lot of money so
the obvious thing to do buy 40
newspapers there's no
data science or any sort of magic needed
really not even so much
math to be quite honest you just know
that if 40 people want to buy newspapers
you make exactly
you you buy exactly 40 newspapers in the
morning yourself
but we just want to make sure that this
is the right choice so let's use our
scipy
optimizer just to double check what we
do is we define a thing called
an objective function this is what the
optimizer will use
to um as the objective to minimize
now the minimization might be a little
bit confusing but that's just a
convention
we want to we want to maximize the
niche's profit so we take the sum of the
daily inventory values for all the
demands that we
have in particular and we just make it a
negative so it turns into
something that the scipy algorithm will
will minimize
instead so here's what an optimizer run
looks like
i want to point out that the this
optimizer function can take multiple
days of demand so we've put 40 in here
twice
so day one and day two and we've said
that
the amount the choices the optimizer can
make are anywhere between zero to
buying an infinite amount of newspapers
and we give it the objective function to
plug a bunch of numbers into
and try and minimize our objective
function value so
we see here the optimizer tries a value
of zero and it gets an objective value
of zero it tries a value of one it gets
an objective value
of negative four then it tries a value
of let's say 178 and it gets an
objective function value of one thousand
three hundred this doesn't this is not
good we don't want higher numbers so it
then goes back on the other extreme to 2
and gets a number of negative
negative 10 and then after bouncing back
and forth converges
on a particular minimization that
unsurprisingly ends up
at 40 the same answer we had before the
optimizer and the obvious answer
i want to point out that these numbers
don't mean anything by themselves
there just means something in relation
to another number from the objective
function so it just tells us
given our inventory choice and given the
demand
what is a better choice versus another
and in this case a value of 159
from the objective function for an
inventory value of close to 40
is much better than anisha buying 180
newspapers
losing a bunch of money for what would
amount to 130 newspapers unsold
and uh you can correspondingly see that
with a very high
objective function number relative to
159
but what if demand is variable i think
you
will appreciate that uh 40 exactly 40
people don't buy newspapers each day
each day so what do we do when things
are are variable
so what we're going to do is we're going
to run a little bit of a simulation here
we're going to simulate 15 days worth of
demand and we're going to simulate it
from a random
normal that's characterized with a mean
of 40 and a
standard deviation of 20. and we're
going to take the first five days and
say anisha has seen these values so
she's been in the business for five days
now
she's seen that 75 people wanted
newspapers 48
85 77 60 so she's getting some sense of
what people in los angeles how many
people los angeles want to buy
newspapers
which she hasn't seen yet as the next 10
days worth of demand
so if she's seen if she's seen these
five days worth of demand
how could she make the best possible
choice for the next 10 days
worth of demand so what most people do
and what most businesses do is they use
the mean of the observed data
we take the average we say hey we'll
just take the average
that's what we're going to stock and
that's what we're going to do so anisha
does that she takes the average
she says of 69 newspapers on average or
sold in the last five days or
there's demand for 69 newspapers on
average in the last five days so let me
just stock 69.
we're going to plug that into our
objective function and we see that we
get a score of 230.
awesome this is great we've actually
used data to make a choice which is
which is
commendable to be quite honest um
unfortunately though we could have done
a little bit better
we left some information on the table we
didn't use uncertainty anywhere in our
decision
and we didn't use the profit or customer
information anywhere at all we didn't
point out that anisha makes two dollars
in every sale but could lose five
dollars for every piece of unsold
inventory it's a it's a
asymmetric um um
value for her if she does one versus the
other what does 230 mean
like i said before nothing it in this
particular case because that's by itself
but it is going to mean something when
we compare it to our next methodology
which is the one we're going to use to
address uncertainty
so distributions statistical
distributions are a way to help us
characterize uncertainty so let's
let's try it out so in
classical research you're going to see
this thing called the critical fractal
equation
what it assumes that if you know the
mean and standard deviation
of or the parameters of your demand
distribution the true parameters your
demand distribution
you get the optimal answer guarantee
and for a normal distribution this is
what it looks like you get you plug in
your profit and your loss or sorry your
your cost to your customer and your cost
to your business
you plug in the mean and the standard
deviation and you get a particular
number
in this case on wikipedia this is the
example they have
but where do we actually get the mean
and standard deviation from we don't
have like
a magic table or book or or source api
that'll just give us
the true mean and the true standard
deviation nobody knows that in real life
what we can do though is we've seen five
data points so let's
take the mean of the demand we've seen
the average of the demand we've seen
let's take the standard deviation
the average is the same 69 as before
nothing's different here
but the standard deviation is now 13.2
okay this is great
given that we have the mean and the
standard deviation we can plug this into
the critical fractal equation
and then we can use our objective
function to see how we did the critical
fractal equation tells us to buy 62
newspapers
less than the than the ones previously
we that we did with the
um the average methodology and given
that and given the next 10 days of
demand
uh we get a score of negative 92 where
lower again is better
this is great we actually moved down
from 230 to negative 92 in our objective
function
this time we took more data into account
we took uncertainty using a normal
distribution
we used the standard deviation to
characterize that uncertainty and we
took in the cost of overstocking versus
understalking
this is the graphical representation of
just that again we have five data points
we got the mean and the standard
deviation what's called the empirical
mean and empirical standard deviation
from the data points we have this gives
us a distribution of what we expect
newspaper demand to be
making an assumption that it's normal we
plug that into the critical fractal
equation which give us the optimal
answer and we get 62 newspapers
but given five data points how sure are
we that the observed mean and the
observed standard deviation
are the true mean and the true standard
deviation and the truth is
we actually don't know we can chill this
with simulation we take uh
our a standard normal from using sci the
sci-fi statistics function or statistics
module
and we take five random draws from a
normal distribution
um a hundred times and what we do is we
take the mean and the standard deviation
and what you can see is depending on
what which five samples you get even if
they're from the same
original distribution the observed mean
and the observed standard deviation can
vary
quite widely this dashed line is the
true mean this dashed line is the true
standard deviation and you see that
um doesn't really line up at any point
to be
exactly the same as as uh what the true
mean and true standard deviation are
[Music]
and so this is where bayesian statistics
come in bayesian statistics is a little
bit different
it treats the data as what's fixed and
it treats the parameters as what's
unknown
and what we have here is a full bayesian
model for our problem
in a full bayesian model you have these
things called priors
these are your prior beliefs in the
distribution of the parameters not the
distribution of newspaper sales
the distribution of the parameters that
characterize newspaper cells
and what we have here is the likelihood
and the likelihood characterizes the
observed thing that we see
and the observations here are is
newspaper i'm sorry newspaper demand
and so this is a truncated normal
um because we can't sell less than zero
newspapers
so we take into account that negative
newspaper sales are not possible
and we say we have this prior belief of
the newspaper of the
the of the mean and the standard
deviation of this truncated normal
these three blocks here are um are sort
of our
instructions to our our uh probabilistic
programming language
our framework in this case prime c3
that's telling it to draw
samples to get our posterior
distribution we'll talk about what the
what posterior means here in a second
and then post the posterior predictive
distribution of newspaper cells again
we'll talk about this in a second
this line here in arby's is just a um a
function that packages the data
together in a nice way so think of it
just like as a data frame for bayesian
bayesian statistics you'll see some
outputs from our
our probabilistic programming language
we won't talk too much about them in
this particular talk but what it's doing
is it's
using a combination of our priors and
our model
definition and the data that we've seen
which is the scene demand right here
and it's coming up with a posterior
distribution
and so here is the pictures of our
posterior distribution
after we take into account our model and
our priors
which is our belief in the parameters
and condition those
on data which means feed feed the the
model and the probabilistic programming
language
the data we've seen we get this range of
what we think
the mean newspaper demand could be the
um the model tends to think that 69 is
the most likely value
unsurprising again you saw that 69 was
the thing that we got in the previous
two methodologies
but we also see that 57 could be um
could occur or or 81 we have this range
here of the possible mean
of demand we also have a range of the
possible mean of i'm sorry the possible
distribution
of um sorry the possible distribution of
the standard deviation of newspaper
demand
again the mean the most likely value is
what we saw which is 14
but it could range anywhere from 7.9 to
22.
and because we have distributions of our
parameters that actually means we have
many different
distributions of our newspaper estimates
so the basis statistics is telling us
that we could have a distribution of
newspaper demand that is this one um
somewhere around 80 and very
narrow or it could be this green one
which is has a mean somewhere around 60
and is is very wide we don't quite know
whether it's this one or this one but we
get
estimates for both
and what we can do there is we can take
all of our estimates for every
distribution and take weighted samples
to generate a posterior predictive
distribution
so we can say hey we're probably going
to sell
around 60 newspapers for sure but you
know 130
or 20 could actually occur as well
this is giving us to repeat um
estimates of every possible version of
the future not just one possible version
of the future i know these are a lot of
distributions so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to recap them all in this
slide
the bayesian statistics lets us
characterize using human experience
the prior distributions before we have
any uh data
about what newspaper command demand
could be from what we observed
what we think before we've seen the data
it lets us
characterize what we think news the
distribution of newspaper demand so in
this case we think
the distribution is a truncated normal
we use
inference to get our posterior
distributions which means combine
our model our priors and our priors
to get mathematical estimates
using data of what the distribution of
the mean and standard deviation could be
this gives us multiple possible
distributions of future demand
and then we use all these possible
versions of future demand to generate
what's called a posterior predictive to
really estimate
what what will actual newspaper demand
be
i know that's it's quite a metal so
let's actually see our results first
we're going to take our posterior
predictive
and we're going to use our optimizer to
optimize and figure out what the best
version
of our inventory holding cost should be
sorry our inventory choice to be
so we take our bayesian demand estimates
which is what we think is going to
happen
we give this to our optimizer just as we
have before and our optimizer tells us
to buy 61 newspapers it's telling
us that given what we what our model is
giving us that 61 really is the best
um value to to purchase in the morning
to maximize profit
we're going to we're going to run this
through our objective function to see
again to see what the score will be and
we see the score here is negative 125
where lower is better and this is the
best score we've had
so far oops
let me uh fix this real quick the
optimizer
can change a little bit but 125 is still
the best that we've seen
um we've used all the information we had
in the in before but we've also
incorporated prior business knowledge
and we've incorporated we've preserved
the uncertainty from our smaller data
size we'll talk about this in in just a
second
by utilizing everything uh including
human experience
and the uncertainty from smaller the
smaller data size
we're able to maximize the chances that
we get the best particular outcome
here it is in graphical form again
because it's quite a lot
we have our priors which is what we
believe in before we see in any data
we have our observed daily demand we use
both of these
in a model to get our posterior
estimates of demand
from here we end up with multiple
versions of possible
demands of newspapers using all of these
but literally thousands of them we can
generate a single posterior predictive
distribution of newspaper demand which
gets us again
estimates in every possible version of
the future we can then
optimize over every possible version of
the future and get
what is the best answer of the bunch and
here's the comparison
um when we just use the mean which
didn't use very little which uses very
little information we get an
answer it's not terrible but you know we
get one if we take into account
some uncertainty and make some
assumptions we get another answer which
is negative 92 comparatively better and
if we use
um the bayesian method which
incorporates human experience and
preserves
uh the uncertainty from adult a small
data set we get um
the best answer yet so are there other
using reason to use base though besides
just that i've shown you this one
example that it tends to do the best
well
i'm really glad you asked there's the
two reasons we've already talked about
are preservation of uncertainty with
small data sets
when you take the mean and the standard
deviation it doesn't matter whether from
a
from a distribution from samples it
doesn't really matter whether you're
five
or you have five thousand you end up
with one mean and you end up with one
standard deviation
and it removes the uncertainty that
comes from a smaller data a smaller data
set
i think intuitively people understand
when you've seen 5000 data sets you can
be
more certain about your characterization
of the world than when you've seen just
five and the nice thing about bayesian
statistics is that it handles this type
of uncertainty
uh natively it just it tends to just
quote unquote
know that with a lower amount of data to
believe the prior is a little bit more
um and with a large amount of data it
tends to know to believe the data a
little bit more
another nice thing about statistics is
it's the distribution flexibility
not everything in the world is a
symmetric normal you saw that we were
able to use a truncated normal
but it might it probably turns out and
this is my my experience in real life
that there oftentimes you know is a mean
uh and a sort of bell curve but there's
a really long tail of possible
probabilities um possible sorry possible
outcomes
bayesian statistics is nice because it
can handle this non-symmetric newspaper
demand
and what's called tail risk pretty
easily you don't have to rederive any
formulas you just plug in
a likelihood or distributions that that
look like this instead
i think the biggest thing though is the
newspaper vendor
the news vendor model is very simplified
which is why the critical fractal
equation
is so simple it makes so many
assumptions that the purchase price is
fixed that
the demand is stationary that nothing is
changing over time that a single period
but if you take any one of those and you
break those assumptions the critical
fractal equation no longer
no longer applies so if we assume that
that you know newspaper demand varies on
weekends or that it's increasing
linearly over time as the population of
los angeles grows or that
a niche will get 20 orders every day or
that there's actually
three different types of people that can
order professionals companies and
students
or that when anisha buys 40 newspapers
five of them actually
are might be garbage they're misprints
or and or
have blank pages she needs to get rid of
them which is called supply side
variability
if we have any of these conditions well
we can't really use the critical fractal
equation
anymore but we can extend our bayesian
model
quite easily so for me it's made it um
quite easy to extend simple models and
the more complex ones that fit
that fits the complexity of the real
world
so we talked about model extensibility
flexibility in one way but it also is
extensible and flexible in model
architecture specifically the model
architecture
we can do regressions we can use
advanced architectures like gaussian
processes or auto-aggressive models or
space-based models
an example of this is the profit library
it's one of the most popular
sort of packaged bayesian models that
does a really good job of time series
estimates and
it does this by adding in components for
seasonality in months or days or
whatever you may you whatever may exist
in your demand trend
bayesian models also have the ability to
share data across groups so with the
critical fractal equations you have to
if let's add a newspaper business in new
york in a newspaper
business in los angeles they're not
quite exactly the same but with the
critical fractal equation you can't
treat you can't share any data across
the two cities even though
they're not even though they're kind of
the same even though not exactly the
same
with bayesian models you have this
architecture called multi-level modeling
which lets you share parameters across
different um let's say across different
cities
and in this case you even leverage so
you can leverage small data sets
even more strongly than you could with
other methodologies
and yet another benefit particularly in
industry
is that you can use the human experience
in a principled manner it's hard to go
to executives and say well none of your
experience matters the model told you
this
we haven't considered your experience at
all i tend to
find that if you the people around you
tend to have a lot of experience and if
you can
code that into the model somehow in
invasion models with with priors or in
the model architecture
um it's a it's a quite a good thing to
do
now the argument people make constantly
is that prior is subjective and it ruins
the sanctity of math
but i have to point out that even with
the critical fractal method there's so
much subjectivity
you have to choose a distribution that
you believe is a true distribution that
itself is subjective a lot of times
when you're doing data cleaning you have
to remove outliers or you have to figure
out the time period on which you look
back
both of those choices are subjective so
no matter which
what kind of statistics you use there's
always some sort of subjectivity
um i.e particularly like with bayesian
statistics the subjectivity comes
right at the front and i do want to
point out although we won't go into
priors there are ways to pick priors
that are
that are not subjective um they're
called non-informative priorities so
if you're if this worries you there's
there's a path for you but uh
picking priors invasion statistics is
entirely its own talk
so here's my opinion i think this will
probably cause the most um
consternation or maybe i'll get the most
uh you know
tweets or shout outs on twitter is that
i think the basic community as a whole
also tends to um have a more principled
workflow when it comes to handling
uncertainty in uh in business situations
in my case than uh than the frequency
community i tend to find that when i
read
texts that are like the critical fractal
method it's valid you plug and check
people
force the problem to fit a particular um
derived model
and that's the way the tutorials and
things are written
i find when i joined the bayesian
community
i would instead learn the modeling
workflow and i learned how to build a
model that fit my
um particular situation instead of
learning a bunch of models that i have
to force
upon my particular um situation this is
not to say for question math it's bad or
it's wrong or it's
not right in any way but as a person
that needs to build bespoke models for
bespoke industries like like spacex um
it's good to be able to have the
flexibility to build the type of models
that i need for my particular situation
and so you might ask why are methods
like critical fractals still around
well i mean they're still incredibly
useful um you can see that they're
they're simple and more easily
understood and if you can make the
assumptions
if you have enough data to characterize
the true mean of the two standard
deviation
if things are the same month-to-month
and not changing over time
you should definitely use a critical
fractal equation it is guaranteed to get
you
the the optimum um it's way easier to
implement you saw that it was only
one line of numpy code it wasn't a whole
bunch of models and distributions and
things like that
it's much much simpler to explain to
stakeholders and i would not undervalue
um easy communication to stakeholders i
think
data scientists can get caught up with
building complex models and forget that
they have to explain these complex
models to
people that don't do modeling every day
um and i would say there's a little bit
historical bias i mean the methods have
been around longer because
um the newer bayesian methods are just
newer they've only maybe
mcmc methods and so on have only really
been
been used or or be built into i'll say
quote unquote practical packages for
people like me
in the last you know 20 to 15 years and
critical fractal has been around for
a much greater amount of time
so here's when i suggest you use
bayesian methods though and it's not all
the time
um actually it's quite to be quite
honest it's not
for me i maybe use bayesian methods for
40 30 to 40
of my problems when i was in spacex and
other companies like that
i use it when prior business knowledge
is really important or it's required
like
people know so much that's not in the
data set or it's not in the database
that we need to incorporate their
knowledge somehow
um i do when there's what's called tail
risk when you have to account for all
the possibilities that can happen not
just the one that's the most likely to
happen
and i have to do it when i need a
flexible model architecture that meets
my
my situation and i really do it when
the decision you're making is a really
really big decision um
it does take more work to use the
bayesian methods but some decisions
are make or break they're multi-millions
of dollars they're irreversible
in some particular cases those decisions
can lead to loss of human life
and in those cases you really want to be
taking care that you're using the
methodologies that best fit that
situation and can help you plan for
every possible outcome
and so let me do a quick recap of what
we've done
um we've learned to use data to make
choices even when there isn't a ton of
data
we've learned uh profit and loss
functions and least how to use them in
in the bayesian context um certainly
we've worked with working with
uncertainty
and how posterior predictive posterior
distributions and predict posterior
particular distributions help you work
with uncertainty
and we've shown how to optimize over
posterior predictive distributions
once we have them and the bottom line
again
some decisions are just so important
that you want to be using
the most flexible tools that fit that
situation and in those cases
beijing methods are just in my opinion
the best suited for those types of
decisions
if you're self-learning there's a bunch
of places you can learn
sorry you can read to to get the best
better sense of all the words and things
that i was saying
so we have a lot of docs from the
pioneer three team
but we also have um i'm sorry richard
mcelroth throughout statistical
rethinking there's
spacious method for hackers book that's
free online
and just recently published his
regression and other stories by andrew
gellman
they do a great job of explaining all
the things that i just talked about
if you're an organization though and and
uh you're
looking to just start using basic
statistics immediately
um you can hire us at pioneer labs this
is why we're here we realized that there
are a lot of important decisions being
made
uh in in a sub way if organizations had
a way to get bayesians like myself and
the others that prime c labs involved
now they can
so we're happy to build customized
modeling solutions for your situation we
have tons of experience across
different industries in academia and
most importantly and this is something
we really value it supports the
open source community the package and
and all of it so
um just google us you'll find our
website and
biggest of all i want to thank pi data
global putting on a
conference is uh quite challenging so
thank you volunteers for putting up for
taking up all the uncertainty of uh
planning a conference particularly given
everything going on and making this
happen
i hope you enjoyed this talk thanks
again